so Sam from looking at your twitter i
see that you just got back from abu
dhabi film festival how was the film
received their versus somewhere else say
Boston argh leave you screamed well you
know what's amazing with the citizen
it's a we went to Boston Film Festival
and the show was sold out it was our
world premiere and it was sold out and
and for us it was a great great
experience just to see how you know our
first screening to you know to American
people see how big and a react to the
movie in it was made that the reaction
was definitely I mean amazing the Q&A
was was great in all ways I think the
most memorable moments are of you know
in our trips are the q and A's we get
these really and depth questions from
people who who really wants to know more
about about the character and about the
Arabs and about immigrations and it was
like we never know anything anything
called like green card lottery what's
this all about like in the movie what is
the secret evidence staying in the movie
what's that you know they started really
digging deep because we're giving him
the right you know ground for it and we
you know what we discuss it with him and
they were really inspired and it was
great to see how Americans wanted to
know more about the East wanted to know
more about immigration they want to know
more about ibraheem himself now we went
to Abu Dhabi and we were really kind of
like we wanted we were eager to know how
you know the Middle East will react to
an American Dream story how would they
feel about it and our first screening at
the Emirates Palace was sold out
screening and we had over 10,000 people
I mean it's a huge theater we were you
know all of us we were really you know
kind of like looked scared it's like how
we gonna fill this theater I mean I
reckon and because it's huge it's like
enormous theorists beautiful and it was
sold out they had to send people back
home they could not even find the single
ticket to come in to walk into the
theater to watch the movie and it was
great to see how the Middle East reacted
to the American Dream story you know and
they want to know more about the west
and they want to know more about
America and they want to know more about
the journey and and that tells you like
that you know that how there is really
an environment for this type of material
why we're not making it I think we are
the one who's not doing justice to
people by presenting the right product
and I think both reactions were really
you know amazing and I mean any great
and again the Q&A in Abu Dhabi was
fantastic we always had to cut short
because it you know it goes beyond like
45 minutes and an hour and we had to
stop at a certain point but Abu Dhabi
experience was just was really really
really great and you know with our cast
and reacting to people it was just
enough
you